[Music]
i am going to tell you
about the most incredible place
we think we know our home but
once you've seen it from space it hits
you
it might be the weirdest place in the
whole universe
eight astronauts with over a thousand
days in space between
them can tell us how being up there
helped them to truly understand what
goes on down here
i've been a stargazer ever since i was a
kid
my grandmother even gave me a compass to
make it easier to find the north star
i love looking out into space and
imagining are there other worlds out
there
is anything living on them
you know every day you're finding a new
planetary system that looks pretty
similar to earth
the possibilities of life somewhere else
other than earth i think are very hot
i like to think that that there's other
life out there
if there is life out there i mean what
would it be like
could we talk to it i mean is it going
to want to fight
or will it like romantic movies is there
anything out there
like you and me
to find out we can't just look into
space
we also need to look down here
i'm going to tell you how clues to alien
life
are hidden on our strange rock
[Music]
mae jemison was the first
african-american woman in space
but earth's orbit was not enough for her
she's now
head of a starship initiative its
100-year mission
to boldly go where no one has gone
before
growing up science fiction was my go-to
storytelling
as a little girl as i watched star trek
i was fascinated because science was one
of the characters
it was right in the middle of it and so
my love for science
really met an incredibly interesting
vision
i was fortunate enough to meet michelle
nichols who played lieutenant o'hara at
a star trek convention
she was really instrumental in the
recruitment of some of the first women
astronauts and
first minority astronauts in the u.s
space program
i wasn't one of her recruits but i'm
really happy to say that she's one of my
best friends now
[Applause]
people are always asking me will we find
aliens on other worlds
and i know they really mean will we find
vulcans or klingons
well to know how likely that is
we really have to understand how we got
diverse complex life on this planet
scientists believe that somewhere around
4 billion years ago
life emerged on earth
one might imagine that once we get life
out of this primordial soup the road to
complex creatures like
flowers and humans is pretty
straightforward
but hold on it's not quite that easy
there was no rule that life had to get
bigger
there was no rule that life had to
become more complex
life could have stayed simple and small
but it didn't
today we live on a planet inhabited by
over
8 million different species
and for that to happen is so unlikely
that it makes you wonder if it could
happen anywhere else
[Music]
as you look down at the earth from space
you see the ocean
the desert the grasslands
you know that life exists
in every one of those locations
and the type of life that's there well
that depends on
what food is available
[Music]
the caves have no light source
when you're away from the entrance it's
as dark as
dark things get
the creatures that choose to live in a
cave they do it for a reason
in a totally dark place any light is
incredibly effective
[Music]
the glowworms blow when they are hungry
[Applause]
the bugs have no idea i think oh light
instinctively fly towards it
all of a sudden they're stuck
the glowworm is a deceptive creature the
more you know the more you see the
more and ferocious do you realize these
creatures are
[Music]
when the glowworm's got its bag it will
bite or puncture into the wall of the
insect
and suck out the inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
surely it's a law of nature that life
evolves to fit its surroundings
if we find life on other planets it's
likely
that it was the best suited to prosper
in the conditions there
an extraterrestrial darwinian evolution
if you please
as human beings we are constantly asking
questions
who am i why are we here what is the
meaning of existence
well it turns out the big question for
life is
what are we having for dinner food is
energy
everything living needs it and it's a
big reason creatures live
act and look the way they do
[Music]
me the complexity of life here
is staggering
just imagine how peculiar a camel might
appear
if you'd never seen one before
you might think it was a creature from
another planet
but its strange design makes perfect
sense
for the way it gets and uses energy
like its wide flat teeth for chewing
tough plants
or a tongue a mound of fat stored energy
that allows it to survive months in a
harsh environment
without eating to sustain a complex
creature like a camel
requires vast amounts of energy
even something like a fly with millions
of complex cells
it's breathtakingly complicated and
requires
a steady flow of energy
[Music]
but even if you're a tiny microbe
smaller than a pinhead you still
have energy demands
[Music]
when we think about life we usually
think of the big stuff you know plants
and animals
but the majority of life on earth are
small
single-celled organisms
[Music]
bacteria
and they have evolved to eat almost
anything
so i think yeah you go down the king
mast
and then you jump into the third hole
okay well you know i've done the
checklist i've got the comms ready
so good luck
[Music]
this is one of the biggest graveyards of
ships in the world
around 50 japanese boats and over 250
aircraft were sunk here by american
forces
during the second world war
some were blown up with torpedoes
others were bombed
it might seem like useless junk now but
for some kinds of life
it's a perfect home
all that energy that was poured in to
make
the vessels of war is there waiting to
be released
rusticles look like stalactites and they
are part metal
and part microbes
microbes extract the chemical energy
from the metal
using it to grow and reproduce
[Music]
to us iron is just a metal
but for these microbes it's food
the rusticle is crawling with billions
of happy bacteria all chomping on an
all the iron you can eat underwater
[Music]
buffet
the first creatures on earth were
microbes
and in the future when all human life is
gone
bacteria will still be there doing their
business
i love my food but i mean i'm a little
picky
and that's because i'm not a microbe
they
will eat anything metal rocks
oil plastic even human flesh
but having a big palate like that comes
in handy
bacteria can survive upon mountain tops
they can survive in deserts
they're in the soil they're thousands of
feet up in the atmosphere
they're everywhere
so it doesn't matter what a planet is
made of
or how poisonous its atmosphere
even if there's just a tiny bit of
energy to extract
simple microbes will work out a way to
get it
out in the universe there there's got to
be that stuff
there's got to be these single cell
organisms that are living in
environments
that life as we know it here on earth
could probably never tolerate
given an unlimited number of planets in
an unlimited amount of time
it's a little bit delusional to think
that this is the only place life could
have ever evolved
maybe there are microbes on other
planets
but there's a big leap between them and
something i can talk to
here on earth that leap couldn't have
happened without a visitor
from 93 million miles away
over the years i've had many encounters
with aliens
and this may come as a shock to you but
they weren't real
but if hollywood is right and there are
aliens
they're going to have needs and it's
going to be all
about energy
up to a point in earth's history energy
came from
heat from volcanic vents
from lightning strikes
this energy was readily around but as
the earth started to cool and to change
the weather changed
a new source of energy was needed
some bacteria came up with a new
mechanism
let's use the energy from the sun which
is readily available
it was a really pivotal moment in the
history of life on earth
[Music]
on the space station we have this vast
array of solar cells
that collect and harness the solar
energy from the sun
and we use this to run all the systems
to sustain life if things don't work the
way they're supposed to that can get
very tricky
very fast when you look out the window
you see
these solar panels that extend
the length of a football field and these
eight ginormous solar arrays
they would go from blue to gold to
copper
color just beautiful
so i'm out doing a spacewalk and one of
the things you're worried about is the
solar panel
trying to maneuver my way around those
solar panels and
looking down a planet earth and the
greenery down there and i realized hey
planet earth is really one big solar
panel also
plants have been converting solar energy
and storing it effectively for billions
of years
this biological magic trick means that
even when there's only the faintest
trickle of sunlight
plants can grow
[Music]
photosynthesis we've all heard about it
right
but have you ever really considered what
it means
what plants do is eat sunlight
streaming from our sun 93 million miles
away
[Music]
and they use it to make carbon dioxide
into starch
granules of stored energy
which plants use to power their growth
[Music]
[Applause]
when i see a live plant their green
makes me know life is possible
plants make a place feel welcoming
like home every leaf on every plant
is like a tiny battery
photosynthesis from plants worldwide
generate around a hundred
terawatts of power each year
to put that into perspective it's enough
to match the energy demand of the modern
world
nearly six times over
a planet packed with life takes a lot of
energy kudos to the big ball of fire in
the sky
plants dine out on it once they started
they spread all over the world but those
first plants were missing something
which meant there was one place they
couldn't go
up
[Music]
very big project
miracle get kept from god
foreign
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
bamboo can grow so high because it
contains a molecule
called lignin
it's the bamboo's own internal
scaffolding
lignin evolved around 400 million years
ago
and it changed the world
it provides structural strength for
plants
and they get to grow tall
from the outside plants and trees are
beautiful
but it's the inside that reveals their
dynamic
intricate structure
these mesmerizing patterns are the
storybook of its life
[Music]
because of lignin plants have given our
rock
a solar-powered skin that harvests
energy from the cosmos
and that harvest supports almost all
life here on earth
the truth is money doesn't make the
world go round
energy does plants store energy
[Music]
so it didn't take long for something to
evolve to
take advantage
[Music]
when an animal eats a plant it gains the
energy
that a plant captured from sunlight
animals could not exist without plants
[Music]
if another planet evolved creatures like
goats are like us i'm almost
certain it would have plants as well
but plants on this other planet may not
be green
plants here are only green because our
sun
is green
[Music]
the majority of light emitted from the
sun
is in the blue green wavelength
it doesn't look green to us because
it has light emitted in other areas too
in red and blue and so when you blend
all those together
they look white
most plants here on earth have evolved
to use
primarily red and blue light for
photosynthesis
they reflect back the green light which
is why they look green
on an alien planet if there's complex
life
there'll be something like plants and
something like animals that eat them
but it probably wouldn't stop there
because here on earth that's not the
last link in the food chain
how do we begin to imagine what aliens
might be like
well if animals have evolved on another
planet
they might not have arms but they'll
still be looking over their shoulders
because chances are
there's predators out there
[Music]
there's two ways to load up on the
energy you need
[Music]
you can be like a fish and spend all day
nibbling and nibbling on your ocean
greens
or you can be like a man of war
and snatch up in an instant all the
energy the fish picked up from days of
nibbling
[Music]
plants consume sunlight animals
eat the plants and other animals eat
those
animals it's the circle of lunch
[Music]
every creature on earth has evolved its
own body shape
to maximize its chances of getting a
meal without being eaten
take cats
i love cats
particularly house cats
[Music]
cats have a very good sense of
themselves they're very confident
to fairly pleased with themselves
and cats have good reason to be pleased
with themselves
[Music]
cats are all around the world
from the desert to
the arctic to temperate climates
for me cats represent one
of the pinnacles of evolution
[Music]
cheetahs for instance have evolved into
perfect
hunting machines
but even they may find it hard to catch
their prey
charlo is the cocky one that she's very
independent and on her own
and as a cub she was the one that was
the strongest
i don't see the mile he's just yeah
he doesn't have a care in the world
as a baby i lost him almost i had to
keep him in my bed for two weeks he was
on a
drip because he was so dehydrated and he
was just the weakest of the three
[Music]
i raise them and i give him their name
so they like my kids
they call marliss van buren the cheetah
whisperer
she rescues abandoned cubs on the plains
of namibia
and helps them learn how to eat
when they're babies and they're around
about six seven months old
they need to chew them they need to
learn what taste of meat they like
where there's a juicy hunk of energy
some creature is going to work out a way
to try and get a taste
the springbok is the ultimate fast food
if you look at the springbok they've
kind of developed into a smaller specie
light boned nothing extra they've got
these long legs
that gives them that acceleration and
jump
to catch the springbok the cheetah needs
to be even faster
so my lease helps the cubs keep in shape
the lure is a pulley system just
connected to a battery a car battery
we just tie a piece of string to it and
you let them just chase it
it's like a kid you have to make them
fit
by the time they have to really run 100
meters and catch a springbok they're
going to be dead
if they do it for the first time
so it's getting them ready for a proper
hunt
they can get from zero to 100 kilometers
an hour
in a blink of an eye
everything is just modified and made
for speed
they have a light bone structure they've
got
wrong nails it's like an athlete using
spikes
[Applause]
it's got a very long tail in comparison
to the other carnivals
so it can cut a corner very quickly
without flipping or falling
they normally spot the springbok way
before me
they need to be at least 120 meters from
a springbok for the springbok not to
outrun them
the surprise element is crucial to them
ah
[Music]
almost 90 percent of the times
they get away
it's rough being a predator cheetahs
are living on a knife edge they use
almost as many calories
catching their food as they get from
eating it
but there's other ways to get food
besides catching it
if you can't outrun them out think them
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these wise guys have worked out an angle
trading sunglasses for food
it brings in the maximum amount of
calories for the minimum amount of
effort
monkeys are smart but we've got a bigger
racket
we've hacked the entire planet to feed
over seven billion of us
hello i'm mae jemison right now i'm
aboard the space shuttle endeavor
over 300 kilometers above the earth and
traveling at over 7 000 meters per
second
my first view from space was a city of
chicago
no kidding my hometown
and it looked just like the map i
learned when i was a child
because the concrete of the city
seemed to be separated from the green of
the farms that surrounded chicago
[Music]
chicago prospered because of its ability
to transfer food from the place
that it was grown to humans that were
far removed from that locale
[Music]
the chicago stock markets the
agriculture around chicago
the corn fields all of that is about a
manipulation of the food web
it's something we humans do really well
our eating skills are epic
[Music]
our brains are so big and complex that
we have managed to figure out all sorts
of clever ways to get our food
chemicals to fertilize cops
genetic manipulation to modify them
nourishment to make animals grow up big
and fast
and even robotics to process them
here on earth there are over 8 million
different
types of complex life all feeding
24 hours a day every day of every year
[Music]
including over 7 billion human beings
[Music]
if it's edible it's going to get eaten
plants eat sunlight
animals eat plants
and other animals eat animals
but there wouldn't be anything larger
than a microbe to eat
no cucumbers no fish no steak and fries
none of this food chain would exist
without a freak event
we think only happened once in the whole
of earth's history
our planet is like a huge restaurant
where
everything is eating everything else
humans
are at the best table just eating eating
and eating
but is this joint a franchise
are there other branches out there in
the universe
the answer to that revolves around the
strangest meal
that ever happened
every complex life form on this planet
including you and me
has relied on the same solution for
what seemed like an insurmountable
hurdle getting
enough energy
around two billion years ago when
nothing lived on earth
except microbes we think one microbe
ingested another
nothing particularly remarkable happened
all the time
but this time the microbe was engulfed
but not digested
it actually survived in the host and
became a part of it
[Music]
this remarkable microbe had a superpower
it generated energy using oxygen
[Music]
allowing it to extract 15 times more
energy from its food
[Music]
this is the moment when life as we know
it
really began
the microbe that survived led to what we
now
call mitochondria it lived on in its
host
and together they started a new life
form
a big complex cell that could connect
with other cells to make
big creatures all of them using
oxygen to break down their food
mitochondria inhabit every single cell
of
every complex life form on this planet
that means they power everything
from flies to trees
to cheetahs and us
think about it we all carry
the same machinery in us
and we wouldn't be the complex
complicated organisms
that we are today without mitochondria
if we didn't have that one moment earth
would have
no plants no plant eaters no meat eaters
no us life on earth would be
just bacteria chewing on rock
and each other it took trillions of
bacteria swallowing
trillions of bacteria for more than two
billion years before that one failed
meal
which suggests it's kind of rare
how rare maybe earth
only rare
for an alien planet out there to evolve
over those billions
of years and to be exactly like it
evolved here on earth
well that's like rolling those dice and
hitting a one
you know a billion times in a row
the overwhelming probability if you find
a planet with life
on it it's probably going to be very
simple life
[Music]
you know we're not going to always say
see mr spock
you know we're not going to necessarily
find uh the the bipedal
character that looks very humanoid just
walking through the door and say hey i
evolved on a different planet
and there are a whole bunch of us around
but do i think simple life exists in
other places
absolutely
looking up at all those points of light
we'll always wonder is there life out
there somewhere
maybe there is maybe even a lot of it
but there's a good chance that as we
gaze up at those stars
there'll be nothing remotely like us
looking back
next time the greatest mystery in the
universe could be
right between our ears
[Music]
you